you would see for this week's 20/20 I
team up with Drew Carey and reason TV to
bring you the latest on bailouts and
bull
ever hear of recent TV but I don't
believe the government has any right to
tell people they can't express
themselves we should have the final say
parents the politicians going on you
might think it's so Eagle actually it is
our country is headed on a tailspin to
hell the reason that TV
I'm drew Carey I'm out of here reason TV
is a website that's part of a
libertarian magazine reason it's slogan
is free mind and free market smell
that's now
it's the smell of freedom it's not usual
that a TV game show host takes on
controversial topics like illegal
immigration and medical marijuana so why
does drew Carey Linda's named a reason
online
well I've picked up the magazine for the
first time I don't know why I picked it
up I was just looking for stuff to read
and I was amazed because everything I
read in the magazine well that's the way
I think and that makes sense and that
just because it's called reason that
like it's funny because every other
argument sounded reasonable you know
what's the message the thing I got out
of that Reason magazine really helped me
out is not thinking of the government
first for the answer to every single
problem the government is the answer for
a lot of problems we have but it's not
the first solution and it shouldn't be
the first solution there's a lot of
problems we have in this country and as
a society where the government shouldn't
even be involved it doesn't have to be
involved take medical marijuana thirteen
states have said if you need this drug
you could use it legally so why is the
federal government raiding places that
sell medical marijuana a raid by armed
federal agents federal agents seizing
hundreds of pounds of marijuana Friday
I'll introduce you to a man facing up to
a hundred years in jail for selling
marijuana to sick people in the world
Charlie Lynch was was making a profit
off of selling marijuana he was helping
people why are you locking him up he was
primarily helping himself it's complete
bull but it's the bull that we live in I
don't think there's anything wrong with
medical marijuana taking stands like
this could hurt you as the TV star you
don't need this why are you doing this
for reason turn the camera off you know
I don't think it's gonna hurt my TV
career to go yeah me and 70% of the
people in California I think medical
marijuana is a good idea I think it
helps people know that I'm a reasonable
person and I'm not a [ __ ] the state of
California passed the law and the DEA
should back off after that interview the
Obama administration announced they
would back off they will stop raiding
marijuana dispensaries in states where
medical marijuana is legal but the
federal government still wants to lock
up Charlie Lynch and they don't come
down on the state legislators that that
gave us these laws
they come down on the little guy at me
and what about that border fence on the
Mexican border should the feds back off
from that the fence does slow people
down some so it's an inconvenience is
all it is I'm gonna stop anything but
don't we need a border I don't know how
anybody can't see that the stupid fence
isn't a waste of money these borders
have to be secured
we're at war it is imperative it is
imperative that we complete this fence
the face is really expensive they can
put a ladder over it they cut holes in
it not as if they're being won if you
had a long talk war you don't need the
fence the wall is bold and what about
President Obama's plans for free
preschool sounds so good universal
pre-kindergarten more education I think
it's a lot of money wasted the
government is going to make sure all the
programs or quality programs like really
seriously do you believe that no do you
know some parents agree with Drew that's
a whole thing it's a scam parents are
being told that we're not capable of
facilitating our child's learning and
that's all it's a waste of money so if
you're a parent what should you do
educate your kid don't say it's not the
government's job no it's your job and is
the government doing a good job with our
highways plan your day around traffic
but a private company managed roads
better so you don't have to spend so
much time and traffic it will now take
them ten minutes for a journey that used
to take 45 minutes I don't need to pay
tolls so that a corporation can make a
profit so why do so many people
instinctively just say you can't sell
the public highways there are people
frankly in Congress who can't abide the
thought that you might be able to pay
for something without going down there
and kissing their ring for the money
with roads people say yes government
must run the road if you only think the
government has to run the freeways
because you've never thought of the
government not running the freeway
we don't say well the government needs
to run these diners cuz I'm sick of
getting a bad cheese sandwich you know
if the government ran it would be so
much better you would be afraid for your
life that the government ran the diners
you would think like oh no I'll never
get a good another good cheese burger as
long as I live at the government read
the diner because the government screws
everything up find out more about what
reason TV and I learned about the
government is doing this Friday on a
special 2020 bailout in both